[Musica]
oggi infatti parliamo di dubbio e di
errore e lo faccio cominciando con una
domanda la domanda che rivolgo a tutti
voi chi non ha mai sbagliato non ci sono
molte mani alzate
e d'altra parte sit in buona compagnia
eccolo qui uno che in realtà di bagni ne
ha fatti fatti parecchi nella sua vita
d'altra parte li facciamo tutti insomma
l'importante riconoscerli e trarre
spunto per migliorarsi
uno che lo ha riconosciuto è stato
enrico fermi uno dei grandi della fisica
ha vinto il premio nobel nel 1938 ha
dato la sua lezione magistrale e dopo
aver dato la sua lezione magistrale per
il conseguimento del premio nobel ha
aggiunto un errata corrige
se andate online troverete nella lezione
di enrico fermi un'errata corrige perché
perché si è accorto che gli elementi
transuranici che lui pensava di aver
scoperto cioè di elementi più pesanti
dell'uranio in realtà non erano tali
perché altri fisici pochi mesi dopo
avevano verificato che il risultato era
in realtà la fissione nucleare
questo toglie qualcosa un maestro come
enrico fermi assolutamente no gran parte
del suo lavoro per il nobel è rimasto
comunque giusto anzi in qualche maniera
ne esalta la grandezza
perché alla fine come dice un grande
scrittore come gianni rodari
gli errori sono necessari sono utili
come il pane e spesso anche belli per
esempio la torre di pisa
ecco allora io vorrei proprio oggi
partire dalla mia esperienza dalle cose
che insomma cerco di sapere o spero di
sapere e parto da questa copertina
questa la copertina e nel physics
un giornale piuttosto importante per la
fisica che abbiamo avuto l'onore sul
quale abbiamo avuto l'onore di scrivere
addirittura di ottenere la copertina col
nostro gruppo di ricerca qui di padova
che si occupa di fusione termonucleare
in poche parole cerchiamo con
l'esperimento rfx di riprodurre un pezzo
di sole sulla terra per ottenere energia
libera da co2 pulita e questo risultato
ha dimostrato che una forma ad elica del
plasma a prestazioni particolarmente
buone e addirittura anche un po per la
sua bellezza ha guadagnato la copertina
della rivista dietro questo risultato
naturalmente c'è stato un sacco di
entusiasmo di lavoro di cose fatte bene
ma anche tanti errori strade che abbiamo
seguito e poi sono rivelate sbagliate
ripensamenti esperimenti sbagliati
errori di chi ci ha preceduto perché
tutto sommato a noi poi alla fine
abbiamo smentito teorie sulle quali noi
stessi abbiamo studiato d'altra parte la
fisica se ci pensate bene ma la scienza
in generale più che dare certezze apre
grandi porte sull'ignoranza e però linea
un'ignoranza costruttiva e d'altra parte
il dubbio è uno strumento potentissimo
che accompagna chi come noi fa ricerca
vi propongo un altro esempio questo è il
grafico che ha portato al nobel per il
bosone di higgs quella piccola gobbetta
che vedete più o meno in centro che si
discosta dall'andamento è la firma del
bosone pensate che i fisici colleghi del
cern anche di padova naturalmente hanno
lavorato per anni per ottenere quella
piccola gobet e per essere sicuri hanno
applicato alla teoria degli errori anno
sia voluto essere certi che quella
deviazione fosse reale perché la
situazione era un po come quella di un
fotografo che da dalla cima di una
montagna scruta con la sua macchina
fotografica il la valle per cercare di
vedere una marmotta no che che esce
dalla sua tana riuscire a fotografarla
ecco i miei colleghi del cern ci hanno
provato hanno dubitato hanno seguito
strade sbagliate si sono corretti hanno
verificato i loro risultati e alla fine
la marmotta l'hanno fotografata il
bosone di higgs ha vinto il premio nobel
e quindi il bo diciamo che il dubbio
come diceva un'altra grande fisico
richard feynman non deve assolutamente
incutere timore ma deve essere accolto
come una preziosa opportunità per la
scienza e direi di più non è neppure un
limite il dubbio l'errore ma è una
garanzia è una garanzia di affidabilità
di credibilità e ciò che distingue la
scienza quella vera dalle pseudo scienze
fateci caso i pseudo scienziati
raccontatori di bufale non hanno mai
incertezze
così è sempre quello no
e d'altra parte per venire anche
al collegamento col tema di oggi se ci
pensate
il dubbio l'incertezza la capacità anche
di fare degli errori e di ammetterli è
una polizza di assicurazione no per per
la scienza perché fare scienza vuol dire
sostanzialmente muoversi sulla cresta
molto stretta no perché esplorare
l'ignoto richiede una grande dose di
creatività ma anche un po di follia
quindi il crinale stretto il confine fra
la banalità e la farsa veramente molto
molto ripido no molto stretto chi chi
garantisce qual è la polizza
d'assicurazione della scienza l'errore
il dubbio la capacità di non vergognarsi
di fronte al appunto allo sbaglio e
tutti noi dobbiamo rivendicare la nostra
il nostro diritto la nostra libertà di
sbagliare perché questo ci fa crescere
naturalmente senza che diventi un alibi
per in qualche maniera collega adattarsi
adagiarsi sul pensiero comune no tanto
sbagliano tutti anche se sbaglio anche
io no certamente no dobbiamo rivendicare
la libertà di sbagliare e allo stesso
tempo assumerci la responsabilità di
ammetterli questi errori perché
diventino poi anche momento di crescita
come abbiamo visto è stato per i grandi
della fisica e d'altra parte anche dagli
errori anche dagli esperimenti sbagliati
possono nascere frutti inaspettati
questi due signori si chiamano albert
michael sommer edward morley e nel 1887
cercavano disperatamente lettere lumini
fero che si pensava forse questo strano
mezzo che sosteneva la propagazione
delle onde elettromagnetiche nostra
scoperte da poco lavoro di maxwell e
allora non lo trovarono naturalmente
perché oggi sappiamo che le onde
elettromagnetiche non hanno bisogno
delle lettere lumini fero il loro
esperimento è considerato forse il più
grande esperimento fallito della storia
il più famoso esperimento fallito nella
storia della fisica perché perché poi a
partire da quel risultato negativo
albert einstein trarrà spunto per
sviluppare la teoria della relatività
quindi dalla documentazione di un
risultato negativo
parte un nuovo frutto un nuovo albero un
nuovo errore c'è un nuovo una nuova
teoria e quindi forse anche nuovi errori
e quindi vorrei anche spendere una
parola sulla documentazione degli errori
noi fisici noi ricercatori difficilmente
a lo ammetto amiamo documentare gli
sbagli perché va beh naturalmente a
documentare i risultati positivi è un
bar molto più bello però documentare gli
sbagli è fondamentale per la crescita
della scienza perché innanzitutto è un
grande gesto di altruismo evita che
qualcun altro faccia gli stessi errori
per esempio e poi come abbiamo visto
prima può veramente aprire anche qualche
qualche strada nuova e soprattutto
aumenta la credibilità della scienza il
saper riconoscere
gli errori da veramente una è una
fortissima elemento che differenzia la
scienza dal dai venditori di bufale no
dai creatori di illusione da chi non
riconosce l'importanza
dell'apprendimento l'importanza dei
fatti dei maestri della realtà ma si
basa invece magari sul sentito dire o
come oggi va di moda sulla forza della
rete no i fatti i fatti la analisi dei
fatti e quindi anche la credibilità che
dire che deriva da tutto ciò
e chiudo con qui a padova una citazione
da uno dei grandi della fisica grande
docente di questa università galileo
galilei che forse meglio se fosse stato
qui non avrebbe potuto riassumere questa
chiacchierata
io stimo più il trovare un vero beghe di
cosa leggera che disputar lungamente
delle massime questioni senza conseguire
verità nessuna grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]